hello and welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of e3 2016.
joining us here today to talk about the
ubisoft press conference it's monday
what are we gonna get from ubisoft we're
gonna find out we've got a panel of
experts i'm lucy james joined by
tomorrow hussein hello dave dewitt
and scott butterworth hello guys are we
excited about what ubisoft might be
announcing today yes
very excited yeah kind of a mystery
right because we know they've got some
they have a history of
bringing out a big game a new ip every
year watch dogs for honor for the last
few so we're expecting a lot of known
quantities followed by something big to
blow us away um whether that's an indie
game i mean
these days like the profile of an indie
game is almost as high as a as a aaa
game like we've had stuff like unravel
show up and be on you know the you know
most important games of e3 lists so they
could come out with something small that
is you know something like their war
game that
hearts and it could blow us away or they
may have something huge another new ip
in in the in the same vayner something
like watchdogs or ghost recon something
big who knows surprises speaking of
watch dogs dave we had a big reveal
about what it looks to last week scott
as well i know you've you you're welcome
yesterday actually yeah yeah chat site
later today stuff yeah so dave are you
do you think they should have held off
for the press conference or do you think
it's kind of nice going in
knowing what to expect they couldn't
really hold off too much after somebody
kind of leaked it with the voice actor
and then a youtuber yeah but i mean
someone else
i'm looking for a reason to get into
watch dogs i didn't play the first one
because it didn't really grab me but
what i've seen of watch dogs too is
interesting me a lot more the whole like
kind of anonymous vibe the dead sec that
looks pretty cool it's very mr robot
yeah um
scott have i mean what can you say about
watch you've seen a little bit of the
game yeah uh so they have an embargo
expiring a little later this afternoon
so covered some stuff i saw yesterday
i'm not exactly sure how much i can
really say right now but um i mean i'll
just leave it at i i enjoyed what i saw
and i'm excited for people to like read
my impressions later today and i agree
with dave that uh you know it it is
interesting sort of the direction
they're going with the game it seems to
have an entirely new personality
compared to the first game i mean aiden
pierce the hero the first game was very
dour and relentlessly just kind of like
surly and upset all the time and this
this new game feels kind of just
brighter and funnier and and
younger somehow i don't know i like the
approach they've decided to take it
seems to have a much more approach
approachable personality and it's
already drawn me in a lot more than the
first game ever did i think what's
interesting about it is like
you could see with the watchdog the
first watchdogs it was like a half step
towards becoming a gta title it was
almost like it was one energy tier title
but didn't fully commit to it it was
like in between something like an
assassin's creed and um maybe a bit of
far cry in there and a gta now it looks
like they've gone full gta with it and
they've got like a proper open world
with unique districts and ai um
civilians that kind of react to you and
that kind of stuff so i think this is
watchdogs 2 is going to be
their move into that kind of we want a
gta thing and as we all know they have a
history of kind of nailing their games
with the second one yeah so like there's
a lot riding on this one a lot of
expectation that this could be the
watchdogs that delivers on the vision of
the original assassin's creed 2 still
the best assassin's creed yeah yeah
exactly throw that out there
but other games that we know are
definitely confirmed we're going to be
seeing some of tom clancy's
uh wildlife yes
um
ghost recon wildlands there's so much
going on in that title yeah just let's
just call it wildlands foreign i'm quite
interested in it i like the approach
they seem to be taking so it's the
cartels it's set in bolivia um it's
promising this you know kind of metal
gear multiple approaches to your
missions kind of thing
dave are you interested since seeing the
um the trailer which had the best
transition i've ever seen a video game
trailer by the way oh from
into the blood yeah that was amazing um
tom clancy games i've always been a fan
of and the whole like i said the metal
gear kind of multiple approach thing
looks really exciting and
from what i've seen it's kind of been
teased for a long time yeah i just want
some wildlands get me hyped for
wildlands so i can start hitting the
hills the buggies and taking down
bolivian drug lords so i played it
yesterday and i am under an embargo
until a little later on tuesday i know
it's the worst i can keep like in this
in the same vein as scott i'll keep my
my opinion of it very simple and i'll
say
really yeah that's it for now that's
what i'm gonna say i played it with
tomorrow and i i agree with his his
handbag oh my handshake although maybe
that's not fair like you'll read our you
know yeah
check it out on games.com really
interested in seeing what they showed
during the actual uh press conference
because after i played it i went back
and watched the original reveal trailer
yeah and i thought hmm
this is uh this is a little different
from what i played and then
so i'm looking forward to seeing what
they show off during the thing and how
similar it is to what we saw it's going
to be interesting for sure um but yeah
my my impressions of that are going up
on tuesday so you can look forward to
that
um yeah
off the rad transition there yeah
they got a lot of mileage out of that
yeah uh we saw a little bit this morning
on at xbox's press conference the
division finally getting a big hunk big
chunk of uh dlc i believe it's called
we still playing the division guys
because i know i'm i'm not
well the reason i stopped playing the
division is because
it's weird like i stopped playing
because everyone else stopped playing
yeah but i know people stop playing
because i stopped playing so maybe
taking an egg situation here yeah this
big new expansion pack will give
everyone a reason to start playing again
yeah i mean i feel like it's the same
with destiny and
you know
obviously still has its dedicated fans
dedicated core group of players but then
interest in it came back so much when
the taking king came out so i'm kind of
hoping it's the same for the division
because i had a whale of time playing
that game scott do you agree
yeah i mean so i actually reviewed this
for us i gave it an eight i stand by
that score i mean it went through you
know kind of a rough period after launch
where they made some changes some of
which were good some of which kind of
broke the game but it seems to have
leveled out a little bit now and they
lost some players in the process for
sure but i know some i have some friends
who still play that game and i agree
with dave that i think maybe this
expansion will bring some people back in
because
you know it sold really well and and it
was a fun experience early on and i
think a lot of people who maybe drifted
away you know will be interested enough
in this new content that they'll be
willing to overlook some of the changes
that were made that maybe drove them
away and come back and realize oh
actually they fixed a lot of the stuff
that they broke and it's now back to
being a relatively fun game so yeah i
mean i'm excited about i'm excited to
see more from them i'm just hoping for
more uh v garrus vicarian
guiding you around the city of new york
because that was pretty much my favorite
thing about it i think they kind of it
looks like they're shifting in tone as
well moving into some new environments i
think the problem that a lot of people
had was they were hanging around the
same kind of environments for a really
long time and same kind of enemies as
well over and over again and in a game
like destiny you can do that because the
the environments that you're in are so
weird and fantastic or you're in space
you weird space stations even when
you're in like future space earth or
whatever it is you know russia or
whatever it's called um there's enough
weirdness and variety to it to kind of
keep you interested but when you're in a
real world location even if it is like
slightly post-apocalyptic you know cold
city um you kind of kind of wears thin
very quickly so like having being able
to do things like going to like the
deeper underground parts of the city and
that kind of stuff looks like it could
be interesting um i'm wondering if
they're going to show off more of the
same expansion or like a more i feel
like they they might have some extra
division content to show off as well
um especially also they have the the
season pass there's other expansions
coming it'll be nice to maybe even get a
tease of those uh another game that we
definitely will be seeing more of is for
honor finally which had an incredible
showing last year with probably
the most uh enthusiastic dev i think
i've ever seen um and i've been watching
more gameplay features uh gameplay clips
of it i'm really excited about it i'm
really interested to see how it's gonna
work it's like a mix of
it's a multiplayer but there's also like
creeps that you have to take care of and
then you get those one-on-one jewels
dave it seems like it's got a lot of
a lot of a lot of games it's got like
essences of dynasty warriors with the
grand battles where you're playing the
badass dude um i played a lot of a game
called um deadliest warriors which is
where like you there was pirates
fighting spartans fighting roman
legionaries and i got like that kind of
vibe yeah but it was that was kind of an
indie game whereas ubisoft it looks like
they've taken the idea of all these
fantastical amazing historical units
that you used to pretend to be when
you're a kid and just let you be in
control of them being controlling the
massive armies and have a really
hardcore scrap yeah
i like it also i was gonna say every
time i look at the one-on-one combat it
feels a lot like oh looks a lot to me
like infinity blade the classic ios game
yeah in terms of like you
really focusing on tells and that kind
of stuff which infinity blade obviously
in some ways based on punch out a
nintendo kind of game and that kind of
style of game it's not everywhere right
now and i think it's it's kind of due
some some more attention and this looks
like it's an amazing way to bring it
back taking these you know legendary
warrior types from around
history and bringing more together in
this one world and creating this massive
epic battle for people to get involved
with you know actually uh interviewed
cliff blazinski who's making a new game
lawbreakers a couple months ago and he
talked about uh in his favorite shooters
there's a phenomenon that he referred to
as the dance which is you have two
characters who have enough health to
survive and encounter long enough to
kind of like feel each other out and
circle each other and try to
strategically like position themselves
and i feel like this game actually has
that it's not a shooter but it still has
like this very nuanced combat system
that allows you to actually like you're
not just spamming an attack button right
you can actually like dodge and block
and and you know um
attack at various heights like there's
high mid and low like you would find in
a fighting game and you have to block
each of those individually so there's
enough nuance and skill involved in just
the hand-to-hand combat of it that alone
is really cool and really compelling so
to layer on top of that all these other
characters fighting alongside of you
it seems pretty exciting it's a lot like
the i hate comparing everything to it
because this is what we do now but it's
a lot like dark souls multiplayer in
terms of you you know you invade
someone's world and you have these two
people who are just trying to figure out
what the other one is capable of because
you know everyone looks the same
initially and then you realize oh that
guy's got magic attacks and then you
have this moment where you're strafing
around each other using the environments
to try to
attacks and expend stamina so you can
get in there and it feels a lot like
like a little really tight skirmish
where there's so much going on for you
to think about so like dark souls street
fighter or any other fighting game where
you need to really think about
countering that kind of stuff the more i
think about it and the more i see of it
the more i'm excited about it it's one
of those games that's kind of been
floating around in my head that i
haven't thought about mainly because
they're not talking about it yeah i'm
extra excited about seeing it at the
press conference what i'm interested in
seeing is how they balance between you
know obviously they have uh like the
speed of the samurai compared with the
the brute strength of the vikings and
how you know that the the knights will
work in a very kind of orderly kind of
way i'm really interested to see how
they'll balance
if you guys had to pick who would you
play us
viking
i'll go night sure why not we have a
three-way face-off right us three when
this game's out we can finally settle
let's roll if it's ubisoft or ubisoft
whoever wins gets to decide once and for
all
all right
we also know that south park so the
sequel to the stick of truth is going to
be there
the full name
south park the fractured but whole oh no
is it the fracture behind just a
fractured butthole though yeah it's the
whole bit
to be honest i think i was re-watching
the trailer and i was i'd forgotten
basically the fact that gamespot got
that incredible name drop yep even
though they said a nine five we don't
that's not enough
anymore um so come on oh this is the
actual moment where he says get nine
five from gamespot um but also they are
very self-referential about what was
wrong with the first games things like
that was barely an rpg kyle the combat
sucked um so what i'm really interested
in seeing now is that they're moving
away from the fantasy and then moving
more into like the superhero realm yeah
which is exactly what is like i like the
first south arc game um but it was
thematically it wasn't my kind of cup of
tea like i'm not too into the knights
and dragons and that kind of stuff
you're still still funny but like i'm
way more into superheroes and you know
every time they've kind of
uh parodied that stuff and made fun of
it in the actual tv series it's been
amazing so i'm really looking forward to
seeing they've got so much material as
well with all the marvel movies we know
they love taking current stuff and
making fun of it so i expect to see
plenty of you know my favorite
superheroes made a mockery in this game
i mean just that you always had like a
riddler yeah kind of off there dave you
excited um i'm not the hugest south park
fan i know
but
the the first game didn't really grab me
as you said the combat was a little bit
ropey
the bit that's charming me most about
this game is that they are quite happy
to make fun of their own mistakes yeah
which also makes me think they are going
to learn from them so while not a
massive south park fan i will probably
try this game just to see how much they
have changed off of their own back yeah
scott do you think matt and trey are
going to make an appearance
they
did at xbox a few years ago i mean
they don't seem to shy away from from
public appearances so it's entirely
possible but
you never know i mean i i think if if
ever they were going to make an
appearance and plug their game it would
it would be at this conference so it is
entirely possible it'd be kind of great
if they did but you know it's fit maybe
50 50. yeah we'll see the one thing to
know is i think i'm writing this is
there's a different developer now right
yes so i've gone from obsidian to a
ubisoft internal team and i'm interested
in seeing
what that results in whether it's a
better game or you know maybe a
different type of experience it looks
like from what we're seeing here they're
kind of sticking to the template the
obsidian really you know laid out but
i'll be interested in seeing if any
there's more systemic system stuff that
ubisoft introduced because they do have
some experience now with that kind of
rpg system they release that child of
light and that kind of stuff so they
have some experience to draw on from
there so yeah i'm looking forward to
seeing what kind of gameplay changes we
might get
so you just name dropped a child of
light there do we think there's gonna be
anything from ooby arts oh for sure i i
definitely think there's gonna be maybe
i don't know from movie arts but like we
have stuff there's a mysterious there is
a mysterious ip there new ip and and
something called grow up has appeared
online which is quite close to something
called grow home which is what they
released
yeah you know really cool like the best
assassin's creed game in lot in a long
time is what people call it and um a lot
of people said at the time you know i'd
play a full game out of this you know if
they took this mechanic and maybe they
were like okay well
put your money where your mouth is as
well
yeah there you go we might have some
like a full grow home type experience
but do you think rayman's going to be
back i mean
raymond raymond did we really need
rayman it does happen
sorry
i'll allow it i don't know about rayman
you know he's kind of i feel like he had
his he had his renaissance which is kind
of like over now yeah which is a shame
although i think he i think he's got a
strong
uh life on mobile yet because the rayman
mobile games are really fun like these
endless runners that they're doing
um i think out of blue bite but dude i
would love to see a raymond origins too
like one of the prettiest games one of
the best platformers i would love to see
like a full true sequel too i mean they
had raymond legends but it was i don't
know it was a bit
it just didn't sit as as well with me i
don't think i was playing it and i felt
like it was a bit
stuff being locked off and just stuff to
collect stuff to do and it was like
that's not just things that can improve
in future games yeah i mean i mean i've
actually
been replaying very bad too i've
downloaded it on the vita and i was like
okay this doesn't hold up but i would
totally play another 3d rayman like yeah
we'll see i hope so um let's talk a
little bit about vr because ubisoft
is another one of the main publishers
that are that is fully embracing so we
know we've got eagle flight
and
i'm very excited about this we've got
star trek all right are you just excited
so you can see kyle urban in vr
yes
all right no i don't you know what i've
i kind of saw that announcement but i'm
deliberately steering clear of it
because i'm a big trek fan so i'm quite
interested but do you think it's it's
do you think it's time for the
developers to start probably adopting vr
are they too early or are they too late
the thing is like they're not
everyone has a vr thing but nothing from
what we've seen so far very few have a
substantial vr game like i think the
best we've had so far this e3 is uh
bethesda talking about the entirety of
fallout and doom being playable a lot of
these especially with ubisoft they
create these very limited slice
gameplays
for vr and it's like you know eagle
flight is you just flying over an
area with you know from bird's eye view
vision with vr like that's fine i guess
but like it's not really a game it's
that thing where they're taking very
like simple ideas and using it on vr
just to kind of it almost feels like
they're not willing to commit yeah but
they still want to act like they're part
of it in case it does become a thing i
think that's probably the safest way to
approach vr yeah at the same time but
if you if you keep presenting these kind
of limited experiences you don't really
give people like me
a reason to fully sink into it like the
best the best uh most compelling game
that i've seen for vr now is is fallout
like and that's because i know it's a
substantial
fully experienced you know fully fleshed
out vr experience whereas something like
eagle flight or even a star trek thing
is like a novelty that i don't want to
pay 700 pounds whatever it is to to you
know buy this device and just sit on
like a holodeck which is fine like but
for like how long 10 minutes 15 minutes
and how much am i paying for that it's
it's kind of like i'm not i'm not into
these disposable vr experiences i want
something yeah i want something i can
really sink my teeth into even if it
means i'll throw up at the end of it or
whatever
yeah hopefully they'll fix the uh the
motion sickness problem by now but dave
are you a big into vr
i like the idea of vr um i've tried like
different variants of it um
what i'm excited about you mentioned the
star trek one
what i like about that is that star trek
is a world who that the fan base spans
generations and i think because of that
people will want to explore like go to
the hollow deck go to the bridge there
was a game years ago that on pc i think
it was called like star trek elite force
and i spent all of my time just
exploring the ship yeah so i think maybe
they'll just play off on that that fan
base and kind of be like hey you can
explore the star trek ship that you've
always wanted to see since you're a kid
i think it's those experiences playing
off people's nostalgia and sense of
exploration that's really going to help
sell vr
scott what kind of what other ubisoft
franchises do you think could work in vr
oh they put me on the spot i don't know
um
i don't know i mean to be honest i'm
thinking more like spectator modes of
things i'm not thinking assassin's creed
vr would you yeah well i mean so the big
issue facing most vr experiences is
traversal like you have to kind of
invent a way for people to get around
that feels natural um so for a lot of
established franchises that are you know
third-person first-person games that may
not work i'm trying to think of a
ubisoft game that's like a cockpit
experience because that seems to
translate pretty naturally with you know
many of those types of experiences
to be honest i would love to see
something that's a little more
story or character driven because we've
actually seen very little of that and i
i've seen a few games where you get to
interact with a character sort of face
to face and it's really interesting to
to have sort of like
to be positioned in front of a a
fake
character that feels so much like a real
person in front of you it's it's not
something that many game vr games have
explored so i would love to see
something that that does a little more
of that i don't know if there's a
ubisoft property that would work well
for that but maybe an unannounced we'll
see i mean that's another one
they could go any number of directions
we are seeing the you know heavy hitter
publishers finally starting to dip their
toe in the vr waters so it's entirely
possible they'll have some surprise for
us but that's another one that's you
know just pure speculation at this point
all right let's talk about what um we
might see so all the above have kind of
been already been confirmed do you think
there's going to be any kind of update
for rainbow six siege
oh definitely and they will definitely
talk about some sort of upcoming update
to it um as far as i know it's doing
okay like not not it had a little rocky
start yeah and the the thing is it had a
rocky start it had a weird like pricing
model and there was some weird balance
stuff but it's an excellent game like
that's the thing that no one's saying
like it's actually genuinely a good game
you just have to there's a learning
curve and you have to really give it
some time but it's it's a fun game and
the i guess the the issue they're having
is it's not taking off as an esport in
the way that they wanted it to they
really wanted it to be a big deal in the
competitive scene and
as far as i can tell it's not making too
much headway in it but like as far and
like personally i know a lot of people
that play it there's a lot of people in
the office that speak really highly of
it and mention it as one of the best
multiplayer experiences around right now
especially like hardcore shooter
experiences yeah um so i wouldn't be
surprised if they keep kind of putting
some attention on there maybe dripping
some new content in there just to keep
that community alive yeah dave do you
think we'll see anything from the crew
it's been a while it has been quite a
while since we've seen anything from the
crew
ubisoft really doesn't have that much in
the way of racing right now and no
certainly not coming up yeah and with
the announcement of forza 3 maybe this
might be the time to because we always
see when
racing games like buses right yeah when
one comes a whole bunch follow yeah so
we've got ford's horizon 3 uh gt sport
um drive club vr so it wouldn't surprise
me if ubisoft do in fact
dip their their toes into the water and
i suppose as well touching back of the
whole vr thing
driving games and racing games are
something that lend themselves really
well to vr as well
scott it's possible to see some i mean
i don't think so i don't i think they're
kind of done with that franchise it
never really worked the way they wanted
to didn't really take off yeah i i would
be very surprised if we saw that at the
show but i mean it's possible they'll
bring it uh to like a we'll do a vr
version of it i mean if we do see it i
think that's the most likely scenario
but like a sequel or an expansion yeah i
think i think the crew is kind of done
yeah they use the assassin's creed
template a bit to kind of give it some
life and try and make it something
familiar to people and as far as i can
tell like they just
the game felt a bit too loose like it
didn't feel like a genuine it wasn't
like a simulation racing game and at the
same time it wasn't arcadey enough it
was like in this middle ground where it
didn't know who it was trying to appeal
to and at the same time i had an open
world which was kind of like yeah they
fixed it a bit with wild run i reviewed
the big expansion wild run which like
improved the driving across the entire
game right but even that wasn't enough
to like oh now it's an amazing game it's
like no it's an okay game yeah yeah the
big question and one that i asked myself
every e3
beyond good and evil too no yeah if only
yeah maybe who knows i mean
i know i think now that michelle ansel
is working on wild with
sony uh i think studios called throwing
sheep
who would be left to helmet i mean i
mean he
ubisoft has been having a lot of like
deals
you know bad times with with their ex
developers is that a patrice that's a
patrice type thing like yeah and i think
i think they're the kind of company that
would be like no we're gonna do this
without you so maybe like somewhere
quietly there and obviously they're
they're kind of like i mean they have a
bunch of yeah they have a bunch of
studios and also they just sold off
gameloft kind of forced to sell it yeah
like you imagine they want to try and
get people like their board of directors
on their side because you know the
rumblings are that you know vivendi is
take has taken over gameloft and is
positioning itself to also hostile take
over ubisoft and the way to stop that is
to really earn curry the favor of your
shareholders and the way they do that is
by creating a lot of buzz create you
know announcing games that people are
excited about maybe not have expected to
be around to kind of raise shares and
get like a lot of talk around them show
people that they know what they're doing
and they have a bright and bold future
ahead of them so maybe announcing
something like a beyond good neighbor
too is a good way to kind of protect
yourself get people on side you know to
stop something like a potential vivendi
take over but that might be me
overthinking it somewhat
speaking of the vivendi um wannabe
takeover at least do we think that if
eve gilmore's gonna be on the stage is
he gonna say anything about it he might
just do the two middle fingers and be
like vendi this one's for you yeah it's
gonna like that
i mean i feel like they're probably
gonna focus on games i think that they
know their their audience for these
press conferences really is you know the
fans tuning in online and fans are
really interested in sort of the
business side of things i think they'll
become interested if ubisoft does
actually get bought out but right now i
imagine they're just going to push you
know business politics to the side and
try to focus on the products that
they're putting forward in fact i
imagine if anything we're just gonna see
like
i don't know michael fassbender will
like walk out and be like hey we're
making a movie and they'll like show a
trailer that is a great point actually
we haven't touched on is the assassin's
creed movie
tam
you've not only did you see 20 minutes
of it yeah you visited the set yep and
you have a really for me soul-crushingly
amazing picture of you and michael
fassbender yes good picture how is the
movie shaping up i saw the year i saw
the first hour of it and what i saw was
kind of like so basically you've seen
the movie
sorry 20 minutes my bad um but it was
like
chopped chopped bits of it all kind of
strung together and it didn't have like
all the effects in so it started with a
classic like eagle flying over a city
but the eagle hadn't been properly
modelled yet and it wasn't animating so
it was just like this toy gray eagle
which is going to happen yeah but like
it's a rabbit from uh
monty python exactly yeah yeah but it's
it's
it looks like it could not be completely
bad like it is there's clearly attention
been paid um to it and michael
fassbender looks like he's actually
acting and trying to act like he's not
checked out and being like collecting a
paycheck jake gyllenhaal no no he's not
he's actually doing it and there's some
interesting like lore stuff in there i
like really like what they've done with
the animus so it's no longer this bed
that you'd like lay in it's like this
arm that kind of grabbed
it's duck right yeah and then like it
allows you to run around up walls and it
kind of makes sense how
an assassin's abilities would bleed back
onto you and you'd be able to do those
things because you're actually
stretching the muscles to do it and
figuring it out um yeah and there's like
a few other like supporting characters
that are really interesting there's the
guy so you've got uh there's jeremy
irons there's marion
michael c no no the guy who played omar
in the wire yes he's in there and he's
his character looks like an absolute
troublemaker like he's in there being
like there's a bit at the start where
michael fassbender's character yeah
michael fassbender's character is
thinking about kind of jumping out of a
window to try and get away and this guy
comes and he's like yeah do it dude do
it dude yeah you'll survive don't worry
about it just go for it i'm like this
guy's all right i like him so i remember
a few years ago when ubisoft announced
that they were making more of their
properties into movies obviously about
prince of persia there were a few a few
short films around ghost recon future
soldier now we have assassin's creed do
we think any others well they've said
before they want to do watch dogs yeah
well i mean unfortunately for them mr
robot exists i they'll still do it i
mean i don't know whether this is the
place for ubisoft like motion pictures
to come out and be like hey guys we're
doing this thing
but then again they don't have an
assassin's creed to show off this year
um so they have some space to fill so
maybe that is the good you know the
point where they sneak in some movie
stuff and they have said they're giving
uh the money or they've indicated that
the time and attention that they would
have given to assassins creed a game is
going to the movie so perhaps they show
up and be like hey we got this but i
think it's too early to maybe put out i
mean the movie that best stands the
chance of showing up is splinter cell um
tom hardy's been cast in that and that
seems to be like fairly along the way in
terms of development but whether it's
far enough to have a trailer i'm not
sure i doubt maybe some behind the
scenes yeah what other surprises do we
think may turn up is it too soon for far
cry
yeah after after primal it probably is
maybe they'll show like another sweet
indie gem like um valiant hearts again
i'd quite like to see something in the
same vein as that because valiant hearts
that gave me me cry man the first game
in a long time to do that to me
scott i wouldn't be surprised if there's
some kind of primal dlc that they're
announcing i mean i think that's been
sort of like teased there were easter
eggs in primal that implied that there
was kind of they're maybe gonna do some
stuff so
i'm guessing there's gonna be some kind
of like primal dlc announced that'll be
interesting in in some way are they
gonna do primal blood dragon
that is kind of what i was thinking that
sort of there was an easter egg where
there was like you can literally find a
blood dragon egg i think somewhere
hidden in the world so
i'm really hoping that that is what it
seems to be and it was a hint for blood
dragon dlc for primal um
maybe that's probably not something
rabbids related to yeah you know oh yes
that always happens so there'll be
rabbids just dance do you think there's
going to be the awkward dancing takeover
again yeah i think so
yeah i always say never just dance game
yeah i mean they make so much money
yeah and also there's a couple of other
like franchises that usually appear yeah
they're not often remembered trials
being one of them yes like that could
pop up that's popular game
they announced something recently didn't
i can't remember the exact details of it
but they were talking about trials
recently so i imagine we'll see some of
that and i think track mania is also
them right track me they had last year i
believe right um and they also had anno
as well all right yeah um but i don't i
i know seems to have just slipped under
the radar a little bit yeah think mania
was released on console fairly recently
and he's doing quite well so i wouldn't
be surprised if we saw an update in
terms of content for that um i know that
there's a lot of people playing and
streaming it on consoles and it's quite
popular on sites like twitch or perhaps
we get something about that
who knows
what's the likelihood of a reboot of
prince of persia
oh man i think it's getting more and
more likely as time goes on especially
with assassin's creed seemingly
being rethought yeah and like you know
there's an opportunity for for them both
to reappear and really differentiate
each other from from each other because
that's what the lineage of assassins is
right it started off as a prince of
persia game and when they did have them
around at the same time they kind of one
cannibalize the other so this might be
an opportunity if they're reinventing
assassins to also
bring back prince of persia and it could
come back in its classic form and be
like this is the prince of peace that
you remember because assassin's creed is
this now it's like more like the witcher
or whatever it is all right i've just
heard we may be going over to ubisoft
now uh the press conference is starting
make sure to come back here afterwards
for our impressions enjoy
passing by
200 degrees
i'm traveling at the speed of light i
don't want to make a
supersonic i'm having such a good time
you wanna have a good time
is
200 degrees that's why they call me
time good times
hey everybody thank you wow
oh my god you guys are awesome
you guys are awesome
you guys were confusing and awesome
and my mom has those boots by the way
she wants them back
uh ladies and gentlemen you know when
you see a dancing crab and a baby bird
with a paper collar
that you could only be at the ubisoft e3
press conference
welcome
welcome
uh dancers can you guys bring it in
behind me for a second just gather
around get behind me here it's a special
year
and uh i want to
take a moment to do something that's
gonna feel a little uh incongruous and
potentially even uncomfortable for some
of you there's no smooth or easy way to
do this but we all felt really strongly
when we were rehearsing today that we
needed to say this so before we start
everyone here at ubisoft want to offer
our deepest sympathies to the people
affected by this weekend's tragedy in
orlando
our hearts the hearts of everyone in
paris in france in the united states and
around the world are with you
and now
and now with a human giraffe on my right
and
a candy cane on my left
i'm gonna make a very hard right turn
and get into the fun stuff thanks for
coming on guys dance away
dance away
the madness that you just saw was
courtesy of the movement wizards at just
dance 2017. just dance has always been
at the forefront of innovation bringing
its experience to new devices and also
introducing the world to the first dance
on demand streaming service with just
dance unlimited
and today ubisoft is pleased to announce
that just dance 2017 will be coming to
all video game platforms and pc in
october and to the nintendo nx next year
uh yes
your life is not complete
until you have a lion singing at you out
of your television screen hello and
welcome to everybody lucky enough to be
sitting here in this theater and even
luckier enough to be watching at home
around the globe because you have snacks
and you probably didn't shower today
i am aisha tyler some of you probably
didn't shower either there's no judgment
here i am aisha tyler and i'm standing
in the historic orpheum theater in
vaguely beautiful yet faintly urine
scented downtown los angeles
it's true right it's
it's underneath everything and the
badges are on everyone's necks and the
smiles on everyone's faces can only mean
one thing it is e3 conference time now
2016 is a huge year for everyone here at
ubisoft it's my fifth time hosting this
conference
yes
and you all know what the traditional
gift is for a fifth anniversary yeah
that's right my friends
would
or girl would if you choose let it wash
over you now people watch they always
ask me like why do i continue to do this
conference in the face of the
overwhelming internet love
that i receive
uh and it's not the money i'll tell you
that
ubisoft is french
they're paying me in red wine and
sarcasm you guys
no i come back every year because i love
games i play these games i adore them
and i love being a part of the
excitement that comes with revealing new
games to the world every day every year
when i do this i'm like a kid in a candy
store a really large slightly masculine
kid
in a candy store and speaking of
excitement it's ubisoft's 30th birthday
yeah give it up for eubie
um uv may be 30 but like everyone else
here in hollywood it hasn't aged a bit
it gets drunk on weekdays and dresses
inappropriately but whatever makes it
feel young now over these three decades
ubisoft has been flexing its creative
muscles giving its teams the freedom to
push boundaries and create games that
are memorable fun and sometimes a little
crazy so enough talk we're gonna hit
fast forward right now and get straight
to the games all right now you may
remember our next title from the end of
last year's show
when it blew your [ __ ] mind
and if you're at home playing a drinking
game yes an f-bomb in the first five
minutes of this show ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to ghost recon
wildlands
i offer the people a choice
to follow me
or oppose me
if you follow me
i feed your families
give you shelter
medicine
and jobs
shield you from the tyrants
i give you power
i make you rich
but most of all
i let you rule like kings
but for those that oppose me
i have only one thing to offer
a promise
to take everything you love
and destroy it in front of your eyes
so
hello it's all yours
ghost hit the money hit the drugs then
hit the king
in bolivia
the coca leaf is core to the culture
it's found in every gas station
every hospital and every town square
and they use it for a variety of things
like treating nausea and altitude
sickness
to a refreshing energy drink
but it can also be used to make cocaine
so we asked what if
what if a mexican drug cartel moved in
took over the entire country
seized all of those coca resources to
become the number one producer of
cocaine on the planet
effectively turning bolivia into a narco
state
this is the world of ghost recon
wildlands
and you
well you're the ghosts the elite spec
ops drop deep behind enemy lines to
create chaos
and disrupt the alliance between a
corrupt local government
and the santa blanca cartel ultimately
going after their leader the vicious el
sueno
hi everybody my name is dominic butler
i'm the lead game designer for ghost
recon wildlands
a ghost recon wildlands is the very
first military shooter set in a massive
dangerous open world that you can play
entirely in solo or in up to four player
co-op
with beautiful environments set across a
variety of different ecosystems
that will challenge and influence your
gameplay at every step of the way all of
this takes place in the largest
action-adventure open world ubisoft has
ever done
now in the gameplay we're about to show
you
the ghosts already have a target his
name is el pozolero
he's known as the stewmaker because he
makes the bodies disappear
now the ghosts know that their target is
in a large santa blanca camp somewhere
in the san mateo province but they don't
know where yet exactly
and because ghost recon wildlands gives
you the total freedom of choice to do
what you want when you want
we put the power back in the players
hands to achieve their objectives their
way
in this case the ghosts know
that their target has some vital intel
they want to take him alive so they've
opted for a tactical extraction
let's go get that intel
here we go the intel we need supposed to
be in this sicario's house
looks like it's upstairs
copy that need any help
nah i got this
okay i'll take a look around
right let's try to keep it stealthy
there's one right there
oh gotcha
i'm in
oh [ __ ] i've been spotted you good
yep got it just moving upstairs
all right let's see what we got
okay i got the intel on el posalero he's
in a camp up in san mateo cool how far
is it we could use a ride you got a car
out there nope something better
you ready to fly
let's go
you got it
according to the intel the camp should
be near this cliff
el pozolo is a high-value target he's
going to be well protected
there's a camp oh damn this one's gonna
be tough
yeah we could definitely use some backup
on this one
hey you guys need a hand
right on time we're going after el
pozolero we're at the east of the san
mateo base
got it we are on our way
we're approaching the camp from the west
we'll meet you there copy that
i hear this el posolero guy's supposed
to be a hard target how bad does it look
see for yourself
oh damn looks like a whole lot of
trouble
tag to look out can you get him roger
that one less to worry about
okay we're splitting up weaver can you
get to a good sniper position on the
south side of the camp no problem all
righty i'm moving in from the other side
copy that we're moving in from the train
station at the east end of camp
it's up enemy spotted
i got eyes on a sniper
wait for my signal got it
now
tango down
let's move
okay wait a minute i hear something
inside
two guys
i got the one on the right you ready
ready go
good job
okay i'm gonna deploy the drone and see
what's up ahead
looks like an old town that santa
blanca's turned into a base
oh man there are guards all over the
place that bad
yup be careful
one down so far so good
got my way in guys
all right let's see what's in this big
building
okay i got him red gloves gas mask he's
got guards with him
got it
and another one down
i'm moving through
gotcha okay i'm close to the building
i'm trying to find a way in you saw
anything else oh man i think he was
dissolving somebody like in a can of
acid or something yeah look pretty nasty
come on guys let's move
all right all right i think i found my
spot nearly there
careful it's more than the closer you
get
only one left
okay i'm in position i have three tangos
in front of me we everything you can
help i got it
going in
don't let this guy get away
i see him talk about nightmare fuel call
us if you need us
don't worry man i got this
[ __ ] he spotted me
guys i'm spotted
that puzzle was running going after him
where is he where is he get out of the
way
okay he's in a white suv heading for the
east end of the camp following on a bike
got it i'm moving intercept this camp's
on full alert guys we need to get out of
here fast
[ __ ] oh get in the car
where is he where is he where is he [ __ ]
no he's moving too fast go the other way
come on man let's go let's go
hurry up the gate's closing
i am right behind you weaver are you
okay i'm good
i'm pulling out
found a bike guys i'm on my way
hey watch your fire we need him alive i
can't get a good shot this guy's all
over the place
stop moving
okay guys i'm clear out of the camp on
the road where are you guys let me know
damn the whole place is going up
all right i'm heading for the chopper
now damn he's trying to ram the car i
got to hit his engine
i'll try to slow him down
help is on the way guys
i'll run this train
where's the chopper where is it i found
it
okay getting in i'm in the chopper
coming your way
all right i'm on my way guys hang tight
oh no no no no he's not stopping oh man
come on come on i'm trying
he's a tough one this guy huh oh
no no no we're not gonna push him off
looks like he's losing control
can you push him to the side i don't
know how it looks up there but that's
what i'm trying to do
damn they dodged it hang on guys i'm
nearly there
oh damn it okay i got him i got him i
got him yes he stopped i'll get him be
careful rides here
how'd you get buddy
hurry up we got cartel reinforcements
incoming
hope you get
and in you go adios let's get the hell
out of here i got him in my line of fire
well hold him off i gotta fly this thing
and we are clear gentlemen nice work
that was a tough mission oh man that was
close
head over to ghostrecon.com right now
for all the latest news and gameplay
videos
for those of you here at e3 please
come by the booth we've got four player
co-op demos and we would love for you to
try it we want to get your feedback
ghost recon wildlands will be released
on march 7 2017.
thank you
have a great show
thank you sir
crime in the united states is escalating
at an alarming pace
the statistics are staggering
centers are oversaturated with violence
and the wave of criminal activity has
overflowed to suburban and rural areas
dissolution of moral
conspiracies a multi-billion dollar drug
trade no one knows the source and
authorities are helpless in stopping
this epidemic of crime civilization is
being pushed to the brink to stem the
rising tide of violence and
re-establish order extreme steps must be
taken
the question becomes
who will take them
hello e3
i'm jason schroeder from ubisoft san
francisco
uh i had the team put together a trailer
we just took some stuff from snowdrop
and said make cool trailer and that's
what it puts out so
that's kind of where that goes uh but
all that chaos all that scary stuff is
totally true
thankfully the [ __ ] is up to the
occasion and who better to defend the
town of south park and really colorado
and really the world than superheroes or
kids in superhero costumes so like the
[ __ ] i need some help from friends
please welcome trey parker and matt
stone
oh look
a comfy couch yeah sweet
i had it
sit down
i know it's an exhausting walk all the
way down there
so uh let's talk about the story
everybody wants to know what's going on
in the but whole don't know yet yeah
pretty soon
well it really
it uh it picks up where
the stick of truth kind of left off
you're the new kid if you played stick
of truth you would know that
and you're the new kid who moved to
south park and um so the the game is
really about who you are
and you kind of define who you are in
south park but whereas the sickest truth
was like a fantasy send up and you end
up being the king in the end
and um the it's like the next day in
south park and the kids have sort of
switched up and now they're playing
superheroes right right yeah and so we
we actually
have a backstory that the kids have been
playing superhero but they've been they
got into a big fight about something so
they're in the civil war
part of their kind of war and in fact
marvel wanted to call their movie
captain america the fractured butthole
but we had already taken that name
so they had to
they had to call their civil war
true it's a true story that's extremely
true but also um you know we want to get
into who you are as this new kid and the
fact that you know in stick of truth you
really rose to being cool because you
became king but in this game they've
kind of switched games until you're back
to being a douche bag again right so
let's see how that douchebag was able to
make it into [ __ ] infants
real gameplay
okay
dude what the [ __ ] who let this ordinary
citizen into the cue layer
uh listen bro we are all superheroes and
you aren't so you can't hang out with us
please do us all the solid and [ __ ] up
hey do not touch that that device can
blow up the entire milky way galaxy
jesus [ __ ]
mom the new kid is trying to play with
the cube of ultimate destruction you'll
be nice to all your friends eric be a
good chair
good sheriff loves the [ __ ] galaxies
stupid [ __ ] look dude we already told
you you can't play you aren't a
superhero you don't have a costume you
don't have any superpowers freedom pals
are adding people to their franchise we
should be adding people out this dork
like wearing a little crown does this
look like a superhero to you
all right all right have a seat
douchebag
not there
that's mysterious
not there either stupid
all right in order to play superheroes
you have to have a superhero persona
then you can fill out your character
sheet on kunstagram do you have an
instagram page
oh boy you're not even on instagram have
well i guess i can create one for you
so the first thing we need to fill out
on your character sheet is your class
you know what kind of superhero are you
wow it was really important to us to be
able to and you guys to be able to
really create your own superhero so that
you saw on that ui that there are a
dozen different superhero classes you
can choose from you mix and match powers
from those classes and really make a
superhero all your own but what else is
new in the fractured but whole
um well i mean that's obviously
i mean
just i mean it's definitely more of a
there's definitely more of defining your
character and kind of in superhero
movies there's always like the intense
emotional center that like motivates why
you have to go out and fight crime so
it's a much as you can already tell it's
a much more spiritual it's a more spirit
it's more spiritual game it's much more
about there's like there's that you know
there's actually a part of it that i'm
really proud of where um
there's a there's a gay fish in south
park and
he loves fish sticks and um
the gay fish actually um wants you to
help him get his mother into heaven
and um so you get to journey up and try
to help this little gay fish get his mom
into heaven and
you're all acting like this shit's
regular
[ __ ] is hard the [ __ ] is hard it wasn't
i hope you all saw the kanye thing
if you didn't see the kanye thing that
won't make it
okay
so but but you know we
you know cartman's the one who's kind of
in charge of telling each superhero what
their tragic backstory was that made
them
made them a superhero and so this is
what he comes up with for the player
right let's see it
who let this guy join us anyway go easy
on him you guys he's had a tough life
it's time they learned your tragic
backstory
you lay awake that night like so many
other nights you couldn't sleep because
you knew you weren't like the other kids
you walked to the mirror
you looked in the mirror and you felt
alone and that's when it happened a loud
noise
you swore you could hear your mother
calling for help
you left your room
you left your room
seriously dude just walked through the
door already
but then you finally reached your
parents door
and what you saw when you opened that
door changed your life forever and led
you to fight and grind
you were too late because when you
opened that door you saw
you saw your dad [ __ ] your man
what
butthole doesn't trust anyone because
his dad [ __ ] his mom and he couldn't
do anything to stop him
that doesn't make any sense i know how
could the person you trust do that to
the only other person you love carmen
everyone's dad [ __ ] everyone's mom
huh that's how it works stupid our dads
[ __ ] our moms right so does that mean
your dad [ __ ] your mom cam no yes my
dad [ __ ] my mom that's why i'm here
don't steal his backstory dude that's
not cool
i can see i can see there's a lot of
people that relate to that story yeah
it's very personal for us and apparently
that does yeah
there's very few people that can at
least relate to it at some level except
for jesus
so
uh
we got that one out
so obviously that's pretty brutal we've
uh got another thing in south park
that's brutal our combat and we've
worked on that a lot together yeah the
combat system is
much improved from stick of truth and
it's a superhero it's a superhero game
so it has the combat is definitely the
center yeah cetera it was actually
pretty cool because we uh us and the
guys from ubisoft would come down and
talk about what this game would be and
we would go back to my house afterwards
and play board games i'm a big board
gamer so we'd play all like my favorite
board games and tabletop miniature type
of games and figure out how to you know
we didn't we still wanted to keep some
of the turn-based stuff because it it
really makes it easier to do story and
so um so we just tried to do a big 4.0
version of stick of truth right i mean
all of those sessions it's a lot of
very real clarity that comes from that
so
what we ended up putting in is they'll
combat space and time
so let's talk about it first let's talk
about space
you're not restricted to a location
anymore now you can move to get into
tactical positions on your enemies
you can also move to get behind cover
you can push and pull enemies
but they can also do it to you
you can knock them into props and get a
little extra damage you can knock them
into other characters and get an extra
attack
you can use some of your powers like
tweak here to get over obstacles
so obviously using space makes a big
difference
totally really
next up is time in the first game your
farts were legendary now your farts are
so powerful that you can use them to rip
the fabric of time itself
it's like ghost recon
so
you can use that to rearrange the turn
order mastering space and time makes a
huge difference i can't wait for you
guys to get your hands on it let's bring
it out with big volume
it gets loud too yeah it's a loud game
yeah
that gets pretty cool yeah yeah
so uh then we did all that and now we do
the business part the business part oh
it's awesome
it's obviously been an amazing game for
us to work on and i think both of our
teams have been having a ton of fun and
we're almost done and now we have some
exciting news news for our south park
fans before we go
anyone who buys the fractured butt hole
will get the stick of truth for ps4 xbox
one and steam for free
if you pre-purchased the game today
pre-purchased the game today fractured
but whole that is and you can start
playing stick of truth right away so
check out our website and for
information and about our participating
retailers
right
yeah cool sounds great
so
we made a trailer if you want to see it
sort of shows what the boys are fighting
about that was the civil war fractured
butthole part of people want to know the
release date probably too oh yeah yeah
i'm putting my money on december 6th
the fracture bill will be released on
december 6th
why did we choose this life
why did we become superheroes
we dedicate our lives to fighting crime
for one reason
to make a billion dollars on a superhero
franchise
now let's go through the plan one more
time first we start with the [ __ ] movie
then we do the super craig movie then
super craig and [ __ ] will join forces in
the human kite movie just as we start
ramping up kenny's netflix series how
come i have to have the netflix series i
want a movie too you have a movie
mysterion you're in the third [ __ ] and
friends united movie after your netflix
series yeah but he's saying he doesn't
ever get his own movie do i get my own
movie not everyone gets their own movie
the franchise plan sucks if we want to
make billions of dollars then i think we
should start with the tupperware movie
right start with a black superhero
marvel is making a black superhero movie
yet now they waited years to get to that
we followed their plan we do all the
real people first and we sneak the black
guy in phase three how about we just do
movies starring all of us like all the
time but then we're just rehashing the
same old material there's nothing wrong
with doing the exact same movie to start
a franchise okay jj abrams okay oh okay
so you're on cartman's side he just
likes this plan because he gets two
movies in phase one god we have to just
go with this plan we don't even have one
movie yet
how did it get to this
how did we grow so far apart
you go with the plan maybe we'll just go
and do our own franchise yeah yeah oh
you want civil war is that what you want
yeah dude civil war [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] you get out of my house
we'll make way more money on our
franchise go ahead i bet you don't even
get halfway through phase one on your
franchise dc comics
i thought civil war wasn't supposed to
happen until phase three shut up super
craig
i didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice
did i just hear someone use a
microaggression
if you have been playing that drinking
game at home you probably fell asleep on
your computer
and now we move from the flatulent
prepubescent superheroes of south park
to the snowy post-pandemic streets of
new york in tom clancy's the division
thanks to all of you out there the
division broke records when it launched
earlier this year and today more than 10
million of you have spent up to three
hours a day hitting a steady supply of
high value targets and trying to get
your hands on the best loot in the dark
zone well here to tell us more about
what's new in the division ladies and
gentlemen please welcome julian garrity
creative director from massive
entertainment
all right thank you and thank you for
wearing those shoes i'd like to make it
i'm not actually that short no no you're
actually taller than me without these
shoes on i'm sorry i'll go with it
and thanks to all the division players
out there who are so passionate about
our game
yeah it's a cool cool ass game and you
guys have been adding all kinds of new
stuff to the game since it debuted we
heard uh just a little while ago about
the underground so you want to tell us
more about what's going on with that
absolutely so in underground
you and your team will be fighting
against a dangerous threat hidden
beneath the streets of new york city and
every time you play the challenge is
unique that means endless replayability
and even better rewards the further you
go
okay so i mean one of the coolest things
about this game is it is open world it
is so robust and you're making it more
robust all the time so are you gonna
tell us when we're gonna get this new
content or do i just have to start
taking bets
i know i'm big and i'm also pushy yes i
agree underground will be out june 28th
on xbox one and pc
and august 2nd on ps4 and this is just
one of the updates we'll be releasing
this year because for the division team
this is a long-term commitment we love
this world you love this world we're
going to keep on making it better for
you that's awesome i mean you know i've
been in love with this game since you
guys first debuted it
on one of the shows that i hosted and
i'm really really excited about it cool
and that's not the only thing we're
going to tell you about today we've got
a little surprise for you to celebrate
ubisoft's 30th birthday we're giving our
fans three exclusive outfits to use in
game ghost recon
rainbow six and splinter
you get an outfit you get an outfit
chad you get the three outfits
good for you chad
so if you're a member of ubisoft club
all of these outfits will be three for
you with the release of underground it's
like smooshing two or three or four
games together that you love don't tell
the other two i don't know i have a lot
of feelings they let us do this yeah i
love it well i'm super stoked about
running around manhattan in uh trifocal
goggles without getting arrested like i
typically do so uh we've got underground
we've got dope new outfits
more
we've got one more expansion to talk to
you about today
in it
you'll struggle to find meager supplies
in new york and fight to survive in some
of the most brutal weather conditions
imaginable
it's a completely new way of playing the
game and you'll be able to play it very
soon even sooner if you're on xbox one
or pc
ladies and gentlemen this is survival
yeah
the blizzard was getting worse
but we had to investigate the rumors of
a cure
foreign
the storm took everything
no food no water temperature dropping
we are not alone out here
come on man yeah yeah
in this world it's hunter against prey
he's out
the storm doesn't care if you live
or died
but some of us
will survive
so much awesomeness now for ubisoft vr
is the perfect technology for making
gaming more accessible and ubisoft
montreal's fun house team built a game
that just about everyone is going to
know how to play the minute they put on
their headsets so here to take us into
the world of eagle flight please welcome
creative director xiaohuto along with
two huge fans of the game palmer lucky
inventor and founder of oculus and jason
holtmann head of publishing at oculus vr
hello everyone
i am very excited to show you the game
today and even more excited to have you
guys to play with us thanks for having
us uh we're huge fans of eagle flight
it's very very intuitive game and the
the the flight mechanic is super
innovative and it gives you that real
freedom of flying in vr but most of all
it's just super fun and by super fun
i mean i can beat palmer almost every
time i play
that that's not true
but we've been playing this game for
months at oculus and we've been getting
pretty good at it and so this is a
really good chance for us to come and
show everybody that we can beat you guys
at your own game yeah let's see what
you've got done man
let's go let's go
hello everyone my name's carsten myhill
and i'm going to talk you through for
the first time ever at e3
a live pvp demo in vr it's called
capture the prey and two teams of three
will battle it out in the skies over
paris
over here we have the blue team
resplendent
in their hawaiian shirts led by palmer
lucky olivier and vicky and the red team
led by jason hortman with his two
wingmen andre and charlie the rules are
simple it's a catch of the flag game
and we will play best of three
so if we're ready to go
let's fly
so we can see the first location of the
prey
right there at the foot of the eiffel
tower
and they have to take it to the nest to
score a point
it's a bit like football they have to
work as a team taking the object and
bringing it to a goal
all right maybe not the greatest analogy
in the world but you get the idea
teamwork is key to succeeding in this
game
paris has been reclaimed by nature we
can see the chondemar
overrun now with
beautiful trees and undergrowth
and nature and escaped animals from the
zoo
like those giraffes over there
olivier has the rabbit
and is making his way over to the nest
right now
he's trying to stay low
using shortcuts weaving in and out of
the trees
taking little alleyways and tunnels
wherever he can
trying to stay out of sight
of his opponents who are trying to
trying to shoot him
oh and he's been hit by andre
and the rabbit is down
charlie's got it
so the red team in possession
oh no
killed by vicky
who's going to pick it up they're not
far from the nest now
and it's olivier for the blue team
yeah
there's the nest
are blue gonna score first yes they are
one nil to the blue team
yeah what up guys
okay remember it's best of three so the
red team need to score to stay in the
contest
oh vicky with the amazing steel and then
flew right into the line of sight of
andre who took it from her
into the tunnels
utilizing gusts of winds and thermals to
get a speed boost
andre looks like he's got a bit of a
free run at the moment
someone's shooting at him
andre staying low jason being wingman
backing him up
over to the pantheon there
oh great kill by jason olivier
but andre has it for the red team one
one
well done don't high-five each other
that's not gonna work
okay the final location is right there
at the top of the eiffel tower don't ask
me how the rabbit got up there
it's an extremely exposed position
we'll see them shooting at each other as
they head up to try and get that final
rabbit to win the game
yeah
palmer with a kill good work
and andre's down great shot vicky taking
him out there
vicky inside the eiffel tower
utilizing the thermals
but jason with the round against the
final score no
ricky with the steel
okay we have to chase on
to get to that final nest
moment and the blue team with the steal
right at the end to win the game well
done
keep on playing
sorry guys gonna have to stop now
for those of you here you can come to
the ubisoft booth and the oculus booth
to try out yourselves so we'd love to
come and see you down there thanks very
much have a great e3
all right
thanks to palmer and jason charlie and
of course the entire dev team i actually
had to play an early version of this
game last year hit e3 and i'm not gonna
lie to you uh it was like super alpha
and i peed a little like it wasn't even
very good and it was awesome so this is
gonna be incredible i really encourage
you to check it out eagle rift is eagle
flight is going to be on oculus rift and
all the other vr platforms this fall and
it is playable this week at the ubisoft
and oculus booth so get down there and
uh and do it now now that we've seen
some flying raptors soaring through
abandoned city streets it's time to
ascend a bit higher in elevation so
please welcome ubisoft redstorm's david
votipka
at ubisoft
vr is about more than just technology
it's about creating games that just
weren't possible before
and exploring new worlds with friends
without ever having to leave your living
room
it's about fully immersing yourself in
these worlds
and going places and becoming people
and doing things that you otherwise
could not do
today
vr is all about
opening up
the final frontier
captain's log starting 2016.165
starship uss aegis is preparing for her
maiden voyage we've gathered some of the
most decorated officers in the
federation to test her limits and to
prove her place among starfleet's finest
ships we're on route to a secret testing
facility and are proceeding to our
destination
and maximum warp
this is amazing wow absolutely
astonishing
when i walked in i really wasn't sure
what i was actually walking into this is
very cool if i could have imagined what
i would have wanted the star trek vr
game to be
this is it
this is what we've been waiting for oh
holy crap this is amazing i mean it's
really his breathtaking that was an
extraordinary experience to be fully
encompassed
in a world whoa
you're interacting with each other and
you're talking to each other and you're
taking orders from the captain and i
mean it's it's really cool so there's
captain helm yeah piloting the ship
tactical and the engineer routing power
and charging warp coil feeling pressure
already i'm feeling nervous now
all right shield's up prepare warp take
us out
yes captain
co-op game plan is not new i mean you
know we can play games with our friends
but there's something
different about being in a shared
virtual environment hearing who you're
playing with you can look over and see
the person and see them doing their job
and talk to them
the team does not succeed unless
everybody does their job well shifty
cloaking activating shields okay shields
up shields up i really did not want to
uh lower the shields while we were under
attack i was very impressed by uh levar
playing that game today he really had
the language of star trek down and they
are transporting captain it's like you
see this makes you push the buttons i
will say i nailed being the engineer
that doesn't seem good
it's a klingon red alert preparing to
warp
we're under attack we have been waiting
in anticipation
for so long
for
the technology of virtual reality to
catch up with where we imagine
we should be and where we all want to go
line us up for war please we have full
power and soon as susan get us the hell
out of here i'd be most grateful this
was
really incredible all this down to 20
come on y'all punch it
as soon as you can here we
go it's your own star trek experience in
a virtual world where you can hang out
with whoever you want and
that's a pretty good deal
yes
guys ubisoft is bringing you the first
ever star trek vr game as you can see
it's amazing and you heard it here first
unless of course you heard it from the
reporter who leaked it on reddit
you know what you can suck a bag of
ladies and gentlemen
here is the man who was rocking the vr
headset way before vr even existed mr
lavar burton
welcome to the sofa i had installed here
precisely this occasion thank you so
much um so it looks like ubisoft got
some of the old trek band back together
i mean like all of the old trip bands
and the new ones back together so i have
two questions for you first of all um i
know you have my email so why no invite
but we'll talk about that after uh and
how did the game compare to being on the
actual
actual enterprise so here's the thing
right we
use our imaginations so much right when
you're on the set yeah you guys know
that um
when you're
operating the console
there's certainly not connected to
anything you you knew that right
you're breaking all our hearts no i know
i know i know i know but here's the
thing
you don't have to imagine in this game
you are
existing in a completely rendered
environment you are on the bridge of a
starship
and you're with your friends it's it's
pretty cool it's so amazing so uh what
was it like working with that particular
crew all of you having had real
enterprise experience i know i can't let
go of the fact that it's not real okay
yeah i know
but it feels real i mean it felt real to
us when we were doing it look playing
with carl and jerry was amazing because
you know we have this special bond that
just like you will with with your
friends when you play
and here's the thing
we really had to work together to
accomplish the mission and what's more
star trek than that i mean you can play
as the engineer or uh you can you can
drive the ship you can be tactical or
you can be the captain but no one
position is more important than any
other everybody has to do their level
best in order to get the job done and
and that's at the core of what star trek
has always been about for me right and
what people love about cooperative yeah
absolutely um so when you were uh when
you were jordanians you were the
engineers but uh in the game you got to
be the captain so what did that feel
like well
i told the guys at red storm that i was
not going to shave my head
for the privilege and uh and so they
said fine
for me it was it took a minute for me to
get acclimated because it was weird how
i just sort of slipped into jordy it was
like that skin i just like put it right
back on again the lingo the rhythm the
technobabble it all you know started
clicking in coming back but i was i'm
used to like responding to an order and
not initiating the orders so i had to
like oh yeah uh uh engage
that's how we start this thing so um it
took a moment but i i got the hang of it
and it's it's such a blast i i think
that they really
nailed it the graphics everything it's
so beautiful but you will forget all of
that right
because the gameplay is so engaging god
it's so cool as well i can't wait to
play this game uh preferably at your
house yes um well you can come over and
then we can play we can play with like
brent and jonathan frakes okay and
michael what are you doing with my
feelings right now no no no won't that
be cool though yeah i don't want to
burst into tears uh in the middle of
this conference so i'll just cry out
with you after but thank you so much for
talking about this with us today and uh
uh you are dismissed uh but you can't
dismiss me unless you outrank me uh it's
very clear that i don't rank you by like
many levels so i will just say make it
so number one i love you oh i love you
too oh my god
okay so
uh we've all imagined ourselves on that
bridge now you get to do it we're going
to have star trek bridge crew at the
ubisoft booth and of course when it
comes out this fall on all major vr
systems
there were no signs
it came without warning
doom came to us all
the desperate few struggled to survive
perhaps we had a chance
for peace
but desperation can trust our seldom
allies
began a millennium of conflict
a thousand years
the greatest warriors the world has ever
known
the reason they fight
lost to the ages
and yet
here they still stand
searching for a sign of peace
i
will show them
i
am napoleon
i bring war
oh
yes
desperation drives us to war
it is trust
that can end it
apollyon and her blackstone legions
crave a world where trust
is impossible
and the wolves among us can roam free
i'm jason vandenberg i'm the creative
director on for honor last year
in our multiplayer reveal
we gave you the chance to experience our
new melee combat system the art
of battle
now
we welcome you
to the world of for honor
in our campaign
be knighted
join the blackstone legions to drive
your enemies from your lands
as a samurai
unite your people to prevent a civil war
and restore the prestige of the empire
and as a viking
well i think it's better to just show
you
i'd like you to meet
i'd like you to meet our game director
on for honor roman campos royola come on
out roland
yes
my brother
good luck
you
are the raider
in the aftermath of war your people were
starving you
brought them back
now
your fleet
sails for the lands of the samurai
in seeking plunder
and glory
apollyon's war had taken us to the edge
of extinction
but that raider
reminded us
of who we are
we would raid
but not apollyon
not yet
but
they knew we were coming
fries
um
ready your weapons
through the gates
i welcome you all
the gates of that fortress hadn't worked
for a century
all we had to do
was get through them
please
uh
that wall was the only way forward
get over here
here
go
lead the climb
uh
one warrior made it to the top
one would be enough
uh
the raider got us inside that fort
now we have them
oh
my fortress is lost
my soldiers slaughtered
soon
i will join them
you open the gate
now you will pay
huh
hmm
that raider showed us what viking fury
could do
the great raid they would call it
and it had begun
jennifer roman
jason vandenberg
if you are looking for something to give
that very special someone in your life
for honor will be available on
valentine's day
yeah
sweet it's a nice gesture what could be
more romantic than dinner drinks and an
all-night vendor of epic warfare either
you'll bond forever or she'll move out
in the morning
and if you're in la come by the ubisoft
booth for to play for honor now for
those of you watching at home head to
for honor game.com to register for the
very next alpha that will come
very soon all right
now
here to talk about catapulting of a
completely different kind please welcome
producer at ubisoft reflections
p.m
at ubisoft we get to tell all kinds of
stories
like how we can go from a massive
aaa game like for honor
to
well to a wobbly red robot in a small
experimental game
last year we surprised you
and ourselves with grow home
the story of our little robot bud
learning how to experience the world
around him
and today
i'm really excited to announce that bud
is back
and this time he's not just growing home
he's growing up
so
in group
bud will take his first stumbling steps
without the watchful eye of mom
and you'll get to stretch your acrobatic
skills across an entire planetary
playground
not only
can you forget your words
not only can you ride the giant star
plants but you can throw down seeds and
use plants to bounce shoot and catapult
yourself to new heights
all the way
to the moon
we want you to help bud grow up this
august on pc playstation 4 and xbox one
thank you and enjoy e3
pete your accent is so adorable you
could forget to say anything at all
and just turn those vowels into words
there were like 18 a's in that word
you're awesome
now at its core ubisoft is a creative
company with an independent spirit and
support for innovative projects is a
part of its dna but every once in a
while that dna mutates slightly
and this happens
now
here are the ubisoft creative director
tag team champion
panty evan
and
dean evans
oh
thank you
thank you
thank you thank you where's chad not you
out
wait so i'm sorry i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
hello i'm anthony levasso the creative
director
of trials
and also
president of finland
hello
i'm dean evans creative director of the
original blood dragon
and advocate of world peace
trials and blood dragon mate baby
together
that's right auntie and this horrible
problem child
is being delivered right now
and dr darling are back this time with
their two cyber commando kids roxanne
and slater play as the rightliest mean
team to the side of mars and defy
gravity on your ultimate dragon slayer
cyber bikes protect america with freedom
flips and ride on the ridiculous roller
coaster of righteousness
grapple and spin all over the planet
use guns to shoot cyborgs
communist aliens and giant ancient
dragon ball
space is the place and the action is in
your face ride through loops loops and
multiple dimensions into the future
come fight me a lot more porn
together forever today
trials of the blood dragon
side effects may include euphoria and
extreme patriotic views
nothing like an eight-bit title to get
you excited uh as you can tell this game
is a beast and in case you didn't get
the incredibly subtle messaging in that
video it is out now on pc playstation 4
and xbox one uh well actually it's
almost out now we didn't want anybody
sprinting off the chase blood dragons
while we were still here on stage so the
game will be released as soon as this
conference ends about 30 minutes from
now
calm yourselves and uh just take comfort
in the fact that apparently lmfao was
back together guys so that was nice all
right
guys
never knew they were white guys
this is ubisoft and there is yes it is
my friends and there is no uv e3
experience without a deep dive into
assassin's creed
you know this and i know this and this
year is special because assassin's creed
is about to go super multi-platform here
to talk about the upcoming assassin's
creed movie please join me in welcoming
legendary movie producer frank marshall
all right
so frank thank you so much for coming
sure today now in case yeah we're i'm
excited to have you in case people don't
know you have worked on some of the
hugest films and film franchises that
have ever existed in our history indiana
jones back to the future the bourne
films jurassic world so what drew you
specifically to this project
well i think
i mean it's kind of simple i'm always
looking for a good story
and i thought that the assassin's creed
universe really had all the elements
that could make a great movie yeah
yeah so it was kind of our goal as the
filmmakers to take these elements
and stay respectful to the
franchise and the dna of the brand
and bring something new to the franchise
that could be experienced in movie
theaters
so we have a new story
we have a new hero dynamic supporting
players and characters so we kind of
mixed a little bit of the old up and the
the um
familiar with a new
element and this is such a storied
franchise there is so much to draw from
uh i think everybody is super stoked to
see that michael fassbender is playing
in the lead role oh yes
yeah it's an incredible cast all around
uh
what can you tell us about what went
into making this film
well it's really a
kind of a massive production
we shot in
three four different countries uh
obviously there's a
an historical aspect to the story where
we go back in time just like in the game
but we really wanted to get the right
team to put together the movie and we
started with our director really
esteemed
fantastic director
named justin kerzel who had just worked
with mr fassbender on macbeth
and he's really a true visionary who
understands the best elements of the
game and how to translate them into the
movie
then we assembled a team of really
incredibly talented people to
surround him with
and
create the world and and using these
real locations and
a team of stunt experts to
uh take us into the uh parkour and and
the elements that you're going to see in
the film yeah i mean that's such an uh
such an integral part of this world is
the physical aspect of this game and
trying to replicate that in the real
world exactly
we've got the best in the world at doing
those different kinds of stunts and
those those different kinds of elements
so given all that what do you think
people are going to be most excited
about seeing uh when they see assassin's
creed on the big screen well i think
there's a lot to look forward to um but
really it's the uh
the multi-layered mythology that we have
that comes from the game
and the uh kind of putting you into the
story we have a real story and it and it
has an arc that goes all the way to the
end and you're being able to have that
same wish fulfillment you have in the
game of being able to see the
the world through the lives and the
ancestors
uh through the genetic memory that that
our character has that's incredible i
mean i think people already
imagine themselves in this role so to
kind of write at large and bring people
in is an interesting challenge but
obviously
uh a really great opportunity now this
is e3 so people are expecting huge
reveals we want secrets we want dirt
what magical things can you reveal to us
about them
frank no no no actually
i'm excited because i can show you
a little bit more than
anybody here has seen already
so we're going to have an exclusive
video
that gives you a sneak peek behind the
curtain
and shows you everything that went into
making this film as well as never be
seen for before footage uh from the
movie so we're gonna
roll that video very soon soon as you
give the word right as soon as i throw
it away well thank you so much for being
here today
uh assassin's creed is gonna be in
theaters december 21st uh so play a lot
of assassin's creed before then so it's
all inside of you when you go to see the
movie and now for your viewing enjoyment
i present
mr michael fassbender
the assassins are fighting for free will
and their main rivals are templars
templars are trying to
enhance humankind through science
i think assassin's creed has a really
deep concept and idea which is going
back into time and having some sort of
relationship with the ancestor that's
come before you
the overall journey of the film is
through the eyes of our protagonist the
michael fassbender's plane
what do you want from me
your past
he starts to learn that he comes from a
lineage of assassins
he realizes the true history of himself
and he creates a kind of revolution
we work in the dark
to serve the light
we
are assassins
is one of the greatest actors of his
generation and best many other strong
characters in the film
the assassin's creed universe is a
cinematic experience the action
sequences are massive
i just want it to be an unbelievable
right
we have to show him
who he really is
i feel exactly the same way uh i think
we've all imagined ourselves in that
role over the years we played the game
but i can't think of a better choice
than fassbender he's
super hot really looking forward to the
assassin getting naked um all right
just me okay uh now for
uh for our next game
your favorite social media giant invite
knows everything about you
and they're manipulating your feed to
tailor your opinion to their interests
as they are fooling you into voting for
their puppet congressman mark russ
invite we have the single most powerful
population control tool ever created
defend democracy
help us tear down an invite
in this processing power by downloading
our app and together we will expose
congressmen for us
join us
hello everyone
and welcome into the san francisco bay
area
the birthplace of the tech revolution
and watchdogs 2's new playground
this time
you will join that sec
a hacker group rebelling against an
establishment that uses technology to
take away our freedom
you are
marcus holloway
a brilliant young actor on a mission
to take back control from this
establishment now we all live in a
hyper-connected world
everything we use
and every one of us is connected through
technology
from the perspective of the hacker
this world is filled with opportunities
when you watch ducks too
everything around you can be act in
creative ways
you can also profile
manipulate and ask
everyone
and you're not alone
you can seamlessly encounter other
dedsec actors
and now
getting into co-op has never been
simpler
but for now
let's deal with invite
a social media giant that's
sure
over here okay people this is strictly
by the book don't paint outside the
lines and stay frosty [ __ ] you um
the bay area is filled with stories you
can choose to explore
but for now let's just check what
happens when the second feel free the
politicians spent out the final evidence
that invites might have helped him rig
the election
yo prince
captain [ __ ] lives over there
yo check it out
you can see the whole city from here
a lot of people out there man
a whole lot of people
yeah getting screwed
you don't even feel it
it's just
no
it's [ __ ] up
i know it's gonna be a hell of a fight
turning them back into people
[ __ ] a man
okay dude you find the evidence and i'll
mount our exit strategy
hey is that the congressman uh no i do
believe that is a helicopter
[ __ ] you marcus the building just went
off the grid we can't get in or see
inside they're up to something i'll see
what
they got armed help in there
something's definitely up
i'll get you inside the system once i do
you use the botnet to brute force your
way in and download everything you can
but once you start downloading they'll
know you're inside it wouldn't be a
party if they didn't and i've got a
surprise
that's what i want to hear
the french
hmm
yo satara i'm ready to go in play me
something fresh
don't sweat the technique
don't sweat the technique
there's something over there
this isn't our first rodeo
what's next
repeat the technique
you're ready do your thing
get back
you're in a line of fire
is
foreign
holy [ __ ] this is awesome you can move
your patch later man
because we are just getting started
oh my god
so great
uh watchdog 2 comes out on november 15
2016 on ps4 xbox one and pc it's so cool
to see my hometown in that game and uh
much like you whenever i am infiltrating
a corrupt politician's penthouse i also
listen to eric b and rock kim and now
i'd like to welcome ubisoft ceo eve
guillemot to tell you a little bit more
about watchdogs
hello everyone thank you for being with
us today
so as you may remember when we launched
the first time uh watchdogs with the ps4
it was a major success and that was
really thanks to
sony and the push they did
have on this on this game so today i'm
very happy to to tell you that
we are going to continue with sunny and
we are going to do watchdog 2 with them
so i would like
to
to ask
jim
from sony to come with us and tell you
more about it
thank you
thanks eve that's right we've been
really impressed by watchdogs ever since
ubisoft first showed the game
right here back in 2012 i think you were
you were there that night sony and
ubisoft partnered on that game in the
early days of the playstation 4
and then our partnership went even
further
a while back sony pictures entertainment
signed up with ubisoft motion pictures
to produce a watchdogs feature film with
new regency productions
after what is shaping up to be an
amazing assassin's creed film
we think watchdogs is said to be the
next video game based blockbuster movie
yeah it's an incredibly filmic game yeah
it looks so cool and
you know
as you know jim it's it's never too
early to think about who your lead actor
is going to be so
i'm looking at the character and i'm
thinking michael b jordan or a tay diggs
or an aisha tyler who is tall and black
and slightly masculine that's what i'm
thinking you know yeah yeah you can talk
about it backstage i'll be waiting
no i understand you also brought
something very special to share with our
playstation players out there right
that's right playstation owners will
have access to all watchdogs two dlcs 30
days before they're released on any
other platform
that's incredible it's a killer deal for
the playstation nation thank you thank
you so much jim
and now we're going to take one more
look at the wild hacker playground that
is watch dogs 2.
ah the san francisco bay
everything
ain't nobody
is
oh
in my life
literally the most fit hacker in the
world
uh and of course what's a game about
hackers without a few good robots so if
you pre-order the limited edition of
watch dogs 2 you'll get your very own
wrench junior a hack security robot from
the game uh it's probably not going to
help you oust a corrupt corporate
overlord with a stranglehold on your
city but it is radio controlled and so
quite useful for annoying your
co-workers and ending unwanted
relationships
all right folks
we have one more game to show you today
and we all know that eve likes to be the
one to announce the next big thing so
i'll let him take it away ladies and
gentlemen eve gimo
thank you
so i'm excited to tell you about
our new ip
from our studio in the french house
the studio has a lot of multiplayer
expertise you know those guys have done
splinter cell
multiplayer
they have done also assassin's creed
multiplayer and they worked
on the division on some part of the game
so for the first time we are combining
the trail of action sports
with a fully explorable open world
so this game will give you a chance to
challenge your friends and to share your
adventures with the community
it's a completely
new genre
and i am sure
you will love it
thank you
it's that moment where i've committed to
leaving but i haven't left the earth yet
nothing you can do but charge forward
what i love the most in the mountains is
that i can do anything i want
it's pure
freedom you know there's always a bit of
fear if you don't have a little fear you
know then you're a little crazy i think
nothing else matters up here all the
chaos he's just gone no one else around
moment my feet leave the earth
everything else disappears
got my own monster it's pure adrenaline
it's what i live for
oh
the mountain is your canvas you know you
can paint your own picture that's what
the beauty of it is
the most important thing for me is to
try something that never been done
before am i scared sure
but fear can be a tool
it can keep you performing beyond what
you think your limits are
oh
sorry
hello everyone i'm studio manager
rebecca kutaz and i'm creative director
igor monso we are from ubisoft dancing
at the base of the alps just a few miles
from the tallest peak in europe le monde
from our studio windows we are
surrounded by the mountains and they
have inspired us to develop the game
that we are here to show you today
up in this mountains sport isn't always
about winning
sometimes it's just about doing awesome
things with your friends and living life
to the first and sometimes it's just
about capturing those memorable moments
and sharing them with your friends
let's show some gameplay take it away
igor thank you
that's good
welcome to the world of steep a massive
open world partially set in the alps at
the intersection of italy austria
switzerland and france
we're currently flying over ugly de
montblanc and in case you're wondering
egui means needles
first thing we'll do is land on a small
rock over there
and notice a man on the right
walking up to the summit
that's another player from the community
from here we can now enjoy the view and
observe the world around us
that big guy in front of you is a
montblanc the biggest summit in the
region
and in the distance you can see the
material one of the wildest spots in the
game
and on the right you've got the rvs
range the region we come from where
ubisoft ansi stands
in steep we developed a really cool
observation tool we call it mountain
view
mountain view allows you to zoom out
from your position observe the world and
navigate into the environment
our mountain range will be populated by
drop zones
drop zones are entry points for you to
drop in the world when you're ready
now let's get back to our initial
position
besides drop zones the game will offer a
wide range of challenges for you to test
your skills
the one in front of us is a wingsuit
activity
another player drops in will follow him
and triggers a challenge
this is a proximity flying race
challenge
we just secured the silver medal and as
we land we could choose we could choose
or move
on to skiing in the agree but we'd like
to introduce you to another region so
let's switch to modern view and head
over to aravis
the purpose of this next sequence is to
show you what it's like to play online
with your friends or with other players
from the community
as you ride you will keep better meeting
other players from the community having
fun in the mountain let's switch our
point of view to follow whose riders
as you noticed the game won't support
gopro views
all done hold on we really need to pause
here too much at the same time
now i'd like to show you something
special
if we go back to mountain view
take a look at that trail
every line you do in the world creates a
trail
and that trail is really cool
it not only allows you to check what
you've done on your ride so you can
analyze your line but it also allows you
to launch a replay of what you've seen
and what you've done
you can rewind
pause
control the camera
go slow-mo
and follow any players you've met
and the idea here is to allow you to
push that replay of your performances
or just crashes
to all social networks so you can share
it with the world
even better
not only can you share videos but say
you like the jump of the cliff you know
it's a tricky one
you can push it as a challenge to your
friends you define the rule
share it so it becomes part of the
content your friends will see in their
game
but let's catch up with our red
paraglider
wow
there is one last thing i love to show
you
steep is definitely about sharing
intense thrilling crazy or just pure fun
moments
and it's also about enjoying the
mountains
uh
thank you very much
thank you
we're inviting you all onto the mountain
as soon as tomorrow steep will be fully
playable on the show floor
if you're watching from home please
visit steepgame.com to register for
chance to participate in steep beta
phases
this game ships this december thank you
very much
all right guys
we got a lot done today and we are
barreling towards the finish line but
before we go we want to bring ubisoft
ceo yves gilmo and all of the teams
behind the games that we had on stage
during our show back out here one more
time come on out everybody this is gonna
be
like the end of saturday night live only
all the game devs have not been drinking
for hours
although i'm sure they'll start very
soon welcome me
so
so as you could see you know that was
fantastic a fantastic game
and i think it's just the beginning
because as you know this game will be
live for a long time so those guys are
going to give you a lot more
so i would like
to thank you all ubisoft teams
and aisha
um
for their creativity and
all the passion they have
um i would like also to thank you all
the gamers
we are only here because of you
we really love you guys because you
always push us for excellence
as isha said this year ubisoft
celebrates our 30 years birthday that
means 30 years in the best industry in
the world
i love video games because the real
innovation and magic happens when our
teams and players
are free to create
free to innovate
free to express themselves
free to take risk and have fun
that's what got us here today and that
is what will drive us for another 30
years and beyond
because
when you are free there is no failure
there is only
forward
ah [ __ ] we got the wrong game
all right guys
you were amazing today thanks for making
this such a special conference stick
around for our post show where we're
going to answer your burning questions
about ubisoft and our conference today
everybody you've been so awesome i'm
aisha tyler we are ubisoft happy 30th
birthday yubi and you guys you know what
to do
come on down meet us on the floor
and do that [ __ ]
well that was a little bit longer than
we anticipated i think um tomorrow
some more oh what
is it over we're on we're on welcome
back to the gamespot coverage of e3
2016. we've just been through the
ubisoft press conference
i don't think even they expected it to
run that long probably not no um
it was kind of like moving it along
eating off the end i picked up the pace
a bit yeah i mean that was scheduled for
an hour so they'd
bang on two but let's talk about what we
saw i'm going to go through
some of the games we'll touch on very
briefly like just dance they there was
the awkward dancing thing
nx is the big deal there
next is that the first western game to
be announced for nx or at least no
there's
there's there was a square next uh
western yeah maybe there was a square in
extreme last year certainly among the
first yeah so first that's very
interesting also that big giraffe that
was there for sure
no reason uh we saw wildlands you guys
still can't talk about it because you're
under embargo yeah but dave what did you
think
well i had both of these
well i watched it so i'm tempering
myself but
i was excited from what i saw it looked
like they're trying to deliver on what
the first trailer and the first teaser
promised yeah a big open world different
ways to take on your objectives the guy
went on about cocaine for a little
longer than i was a bit comfortable with
i mean he's clearly seen narcos yes so
i guess what we'll say is yeah i was
going to say what can you say at this
point just want to point out there was
no gameplay shown
yeah you did so it was like
they weren't that wasn't yeah playing
live on stage that wasn't live i mean
the thing is i hope like that's all
we'll say i definitely hope that wasn't
people playing live on stage because no
one talks like that yeah yeah that was a
very choreographed yeah
and man it was yeah it was i i can't say
it it was very these guys were pretty
chill
all i can say is i'm excited about that
game
whatever that is i'm excited about it
well it's still a little while off yet i
think my favorite part of the whole
press conference was obviously what's
coming up next which was south park
that was a fantastic reveal because i
thought it was going into watchdogs they
had uh the snowdrop engine stuff so it
could be the division and then it was
just
yeah they did some they did some some
digs yeah they they went straight for
kanye like yeah just insulted his his
game about his mother going into heaven
yeah which is like savage just brutal
completely and then just went straight
into like
taking apart marvel's faze movie plan
which is what's causing the civil war
between the kids oh yeah i mean some of
it as well it was uh again the south
park near the knuckle yeah humor that we
all know and love but also i just love
how much the the title of the game lends
itself to innuendo like that poor the
poor dev who was saying so what's new
with the fractured button yeah can i can
we see more of the fractured butthole i
guarantee they named it that just so
that everyone would have to repeat it
over and over oh yeah they were laughing
to themselves so hard when they named
this game i promise but like what we're
seeing on the screen now is they've
revamped the combat system yeah it looks
it looks like we were suggesting like
it's it's completely being redone
instead of taking most of what obsidian
did it's it's designed to be more of an
active game because you are playing
superheroes you get to pick classes you
can do different like super super power
moves and it looks really cool and
really fun the first game stick of truth
was genuinely funny and it's very
difficult to be genuinely funny in a
video game few companies can manage it
yeah and it was it was hilarious it was
crude purell and the way that we love
south park being so like this looks like
it's going to be along the same lines i
am mega excited about this game well up
for it
yeah dave
well like i said before i'm not a big
fan of south park but even this game
made me laugh yeah i might it might be
the thing that gets me in to more south
park and like you said the combat looks
a lot more interesting than the last
game did as well yeah not just all three
standing on one side you get this
movement involved scott
i might save some of my opinions for an
angry twitter rant but i'm angry twitter
it's looking better than the first game
i appreciate that they've like added
some depth to the combat it's looking
like it might actually be pretty fun and
i do love the the whole premise of it
basically being like a big giant rip on
marble yeah i mean especially when you
said oh my god you're dc like that was
an amazing burn as uh the whole black
panther bit wow which was wow just they
really went places with that with the
satire there yeah
yeah it's almost the point of being like
a bit spiteful and a bit like
crossing the line-ish but
i don't know some people argue that's
what south park does best and i don't
know i don't know about that but
as we predicted we saw more of the
division so what's interesting to note
here is julian garrity who they had up
on stage was actually lead on the crew
so i'm just gonna assume that game got
quietly no more support for the crew if
they've lost their key talent but you
know with underground's coming out june
28th uh august 2nd on xbox august 2nd on
ps4 we also saw challenge
survival survival which is their next
uh dlc it was hard to tell what it was
what it was it seemed like it was just
what we're used to playing yeah it's
like you're in a city and you're getting
chased and there's snow it's like yeah
that's that's in the game but the one
thing that was really cool is at the
very end like the guy with all the
division arm bands like he like was
collecting the skulls of agents yeah
essentially
i'm really hoping that that's just some
guy who roams the city and you have to
kind of like find him and fight him or
you know gang up with other people to
take him down because he's just that
impossible to defeat that might be
really cool yeah
and then came time for the vr segment so
we saw a bunch of eagle flight you know
palmer lucky on stage that is i've i've
never expected i'd see uh you know
eagles fighting over a rabbit being
shoutcasted on the internet yeah which
was insane i mean there was no rabbits
but there was that that one rabbit yeah
but like the way they were treating it
like is some sort of esports and like
palmer lucky with his
weird sound
like just playing it and he killed me
the next big esport yeah sandals
sandal wearing competitive sandals but
like it looked okay um yeah it's it's
good that you're always in motion
because when you slow down and look
around you're like wow this game is very
bare bones but it's stylized enough to
be kind of visually striking when you're
flying through it yeah but yeah i don't
know how how how long that premise is
going to be fun for
um i guess you could make it interesting
and extend its life by creating loads of
different maps and that kind of stuff
but
i don't know how how i feel about you
know competitive eagle flights
also you need like six people to have an
oculus rift and this game yeah who would
you actually get a good game out of it
yeah i'm through you could play online
but yeah i'm with you the gameplay seems
kind of thin i don't know how much you
could really do with it it's more a
little party trick and then
put it back constant screeching from
eagles so i thought you meant palmer
lucky all right
that was parmesan
yeah but then there are the vr games of
course star trek um nice little
video feature with carl urban uh jerry
ryan and levar burton
who
i basically star trek the gamer it kind
of looks like um if you've played that
iphone game
is it uh i wrote it down
space team on iphone it's space team
meets uh meets yelling
or everybody else
you're talking about nobody explodes
fantastic yeah it's basically a mixture
of that which um
is like what i was saying earlier like
we need substantial experiences but
that's kind of i think might just kind
of be creeping up to that like because
space team was a very simple game but
it's
in groups it was very very fun and and
it had a lot of longevity to it i played
it a whole lot um it's clear that they
took inspiration from space team like
it's very obvious that they're doing
that i mean it's more choices yeah yeah
and yeah was itself a kind of parody on
the kind of star trek on on on the
bridge you know telling people what to
do that kind of thing it did kind of
laugh a little bit when the barber and
said the graphics were great yeah
but it's so charming yeah oh no
seriously i mean i'm a big track fan so
i was like
um and then i mean i think the game of
the press conference all of us judging
by our reaction was for honor oh yeah
so look at single player
from the sounds of it sounds like
there's three single-player campaigns
that was the vibe i got yeah yeah yeah
it was it wasn't super clear but they
were talking they described what each
campaign would essentially entail yeah
in like so yeah they
it remains to be seen i guess but it
seems very likely that each of the
factions will get their own campaign
what's interesting is that they said
that um you know as the knights he
joined the blackstone legions as the
samurai trying to prevent a civil war uh
and then when it came to the vikings
they showed this which is the vikings
directly attacking the thing so i'd be
interested to see if you did play all
three campaigns how much
uh overlap and interaction there is yeah
that would intertwine in some way that'd
be really cool i'm also hoping that it's
kind of story driven or there's a little
more substance to it and it's not just
you know preparing you for the
multiplayer yeah
a lot of developers seem to be doing
that kind of thing now like um siege is
another ubisoft game that you know they
had these sort of single-player missions
but really they were just kind of
teaching the mechanics so you could jump
into multiplayer and they were fun but
it wasn't really a true campaign so kind
of hoping for honor like really goes for
it and does a robust complete story
driven campaign it looks stunning as
well and the combat seems to flow really
well um and like we were discussing
earlier it looks like there is a lot of
nuance and strategy to the to the
moment-to-moment gameplay and combat um
there was a lot of contextual combat as
well yeah yeah thrown off at the top
people being thrown into the spikes yeah
i'd be quite interested to see how the
combat differs between each faction like
the vibe we got from the vikings is that
they're they're big heavy hitters there
was a lot of weight behind all their
moves i'd assume that the samurai are a
bit more fluid a bit more agile maybe
the knights are somewhere in between but
not only could there be three different
stories but it'd be like three different
ways to play as well yeah which would be
very exciting and also i mean a lot of
the comparisons online were saying it
looks like ryze son of rome i'm
definitely getting that vibe but it i
don't know there's something more about
this game it looks more interesting to
me than i mean when you look at the
story mode it kind of feels in terms of
the scope and the set piece is almost
god of warish yes and then when you're
in the big battles it's like it's almost
dynasty warrior essentially like you
you're just kind of like rushing through
this area thinning out the hordes of you
know enemies to get to this one point
where a special type is there so you can
wipe them out and move on
it looks like it's drawing from a lot of
these games and
it's just the level of polish that we're
already seeing is really really like
exciting and they it looks like they've
figured out how they want combat to work
and they seem to have made it look fluid
and and like yeah interesting so yeah
i'm really excited i think it was
probably the game of day showing yeah
for sure uh another game that we knew
about because it leaked just before it
went out but grow grow up
um i'm really proud because ubisoft
reflections are from newcastle so having
a geordie on stage was incredible
game look cute as a little cutie
platformer
um
i don't know i'll play it but i'm not
really hyped about it it's it's you know
it didn't have the same impact as
something like child of light where you
kind of see it and just are immediately
mesmerized but yeah i mean girl home was
it was a cute fun little game and it
seems like grow up is going to you know
expand on those same mechanics so i have
faith that the team is going to do
something really clever and really cute
and endearing with it so i mean yeah i
will certainly play it again i agree
with you it's like you can't get quite
as hyped about that as maybe some of the
other stuff they showed but yeah hey i'm
happy it's in there it's really nice of
a game that's not just like blood and
gore and violence all the time like you
need a bit of a palate cleanser every
now and then was it was a surprise for a
lot of people
and it came out of nowhere and it was
out before you knew it and everyone that
played it were like wow this is actually
really quite cute and um the thing
that's going to really gonna like sell
it for for this one is how far they go
with it whether they overextend or not
like i'm hoping that they just it looks
like they've introduced a few new ideas
and spread out the you know made the
environment that you're exploring a
little bigger and hopefully it's just
that like still maybe like a four or
five hour experience and it doesn't try
to be this big long you know trending
things because if they can keep it short
and sweet again they can recapture some
of that kind of you know shock and awe
that you get from a game that just
appears out of nowhere so it's all about
how big they're kind of going with it
hopefully and then after that we had
trials of the blood dragon i think when
everyone saw the guy from trials and
dean evans a guy from blood dragon come
out we kind of
you already kind of knew what you were
in for
um what do we think has the trials boat
kind of sailed now i don't know it's
interesting because trials is a game
that classically makes a lot of people
like super super tense especially in
those later levels they are
epically hard
but then blood dragon also makes
everyone so happy because it's so kooky
crazy it's all the nostalgia fuel that
we we adore so combining something that
makes people so gleeful and unhappy with
something that can really make your skin
crawl with frustration
it's going to be interesting to see how
it works especially with all the new
editions like they had guns in there and
there were people on foot at times so i
don't know how they're gonna actually
vehicles yeah exactly gonna blend those
two types of
it gamepl those itches more of that but
with neon and dragons pretty much uh and
then we came to um
well let's just say it's the bit where i
should have went to pee the assassin's
creed oh yeah no
no
game at all to show
um but we did get frank marshall he was
a big shot hollywood producer
based on laura blanken
yeah i mean i can't help but think that
um poor
michael fassbender didn't really look
that thrilled to be shooting that promo
um what do we think from what we saw it
was more of the same trailer yeah it was
a lot of the same footage that we'd seen
previously and
the guy just like he he didn't seem to
be like all day he was just like oh yeah
i'm here to talk about
some movies some game game people and
then he would just get out of here and
go to the pub or whatever but like he
didn't say anything interesting like his
classic it was the most pr moment of
that thing because yeah it was like
a man he's just churning out pr crap i
mean whatever yeah all right you got
your movie coming get on like get off
yeah it was like another step on his
price jacket i felt like it didn't it
didn't feel
i mean like they could have addressed
any of the you know the fan concerns
that they're setting most of it in the
present day or you know
just something i don't know i think
has just forgotten how to do an e3
presser without mentioning assassin's
creed they needed to at least say the
words assassin's creed get it off their
chest and then move on yeah uh then we
have watchdogs too which looks fine yeah
it looks good we saw that character yeah
that final trailer with him you know
cutting between transitions and stuff
like that it was really cool yeah great
music selection yeah the the music in
the game has so far like from what i've
seen has been great they're like really
well curated selection of licensed
tracks and yeah the world is much
brighter and much more alive and has
much more personality um it's just a
game that i actually want to play i mean
the first game was so like stark and
empty um it's really nice to see that it
kind of grew a sense of humor between
the first and second games yeah there's
certain moments in there where it's like
feels like pandering to millennials a
little too hard it feels very forced but
if you can kind of stomach that i i
think it actually looks like a very fun
game uh
building on what the first game did well
but injecting welcome new personality
also i don't know why this hacker dude
is wearing the name of his hacking group
on his t-shirt
yeah why is this there
infiltration mission and immediately
like
no one will know one of his senses by
putting blasting music on it's like what
are you doing dude like what if someone
walks up behind you and just like smacks
you in the back of the head you want to
hear it coming there's some silliness
yeah and also the news that watch dogs
is gonna be turned into a movie which um
yeah they actually talked about they
already said that so it wasn't really
good i don't know why we had a sony's
jim ryan come out to talk about that
like because they wanted another jordy
on stage that's why i guess i guess so
many pictures might be involved in some
capacity then yeah and then their final
reveal new ip ssx tricky
meets the wingsu challenge from just
cause meets the wingsuit from far cry
it's steep
i'm kind of a little confused about this
game like yeah you said during the uh
the trailer who is this for yeah extreme
sports fans when i saw the trailer i was
just thinking
man wouldn't the new ssx game be really
good yeah instead we're with stuck with
a game that doesn't it doesn't seem like
it knows what it wants to be like there
were moments where it's like yeah
extreme sports and then there were
people laughing at the characters
getting hurt and then it was like an
almost environmental message of like
love the mountains and all the sights it
was a little confused yeah yeah although
i mean oh sorry lucy oh no i was gonna
say it kind of felt like it was trying
to put the tricky stuff in but but it
was doing it very seriously it tried to
do you know when you you bail in trials
and you do the quick restart it tried to
look like it was doing that it's put a
photo mode in it's got what looks like
kind of the crew you know like people
seamlessly joining you and beating your
challenges and stuff so overall it just
looks like a very ubisoft game in a
completely different
i i never would have expected this to be
honest in the game's defense i do like
the idea of a game that is
almost more exploration driven than
maybe we're giving it credit for it yeah
it is sort of just about hey you're on a
mountain you have the freedom to kind of
go and do what you want and just sort of
feel immersed in this environment i
think for certain people that's going to
be very appealing and the idea that you
have multiple activities to engage in
while you're in that environment yeah
hopefully it'll be enough to keep you
busy and uh and have some fun with the
game i mean i think i'm interesting to
actually play it and figure out what
it's really trying to do
but you know i'm intrigued i don't want
to completely write it off just yet i
really do wonder how much of an audience
there is for a very sim type heavy kind
of very bland looking uh you know skiing
or you know extreme sports type game
like the ones that are memorable and the
ones that have the best chance of
succeeding are the ones that are like a
little over over the top in a way like
yeah i hate to bring up ssx tricky again
but it's never like the the kind of
simple this is how exactly how it would
feel to be skiing that really like
captures everyone's imagination there's
always a spin on it in the same way that
for example a simulation racing game is
not you know forza is good but like
forza horizon is where it's fun and it's
what really people love and talk about
in the same way that you know ssx
3 or versus ssx tricky which one do they
talk about it's everyone loves tricky
like they don't love the you know the
very bland simulation style games but
i'm sure there will be an audience but i
don't know i feel like they're kind of
limiting themselves by trying to be like
very you know serious toned we're going
to explore the mountains and you're
going to be one with nature no we need
to do like backflips and what do you
have against nature tomorrow come on
down with nature is what i say i find it
quite a surprising reveal given that
this is the you know ub 30.
um i imagine more of a big
blockbuster at the end i guess i mean
steep will find its audience
but i don't know if it's
as mass-market as
some of the other titles apparently the
audience is not the people on this couch
to be honest we don't really go outside
yeah so all the reason to play this game
instead that's true also there was a
game i think it came out um it was
definitely being in development for ps4
snow i think it was called it was yeah
first person
uh i played it in the oculus once and
that was
when i saw steep i mentioned
playing that in vr yeah would be more
interesting than playing it normally
yeah until you do a flip until you like
and then throw it oh that'd be fun i'm
gonna do it
um so no beyond good and evil too there
was a leaked running order that went out
just as the show was starting and it
said there would be two new ips sadly
that second one didn't materialize at
the end unless it was referring to blood
dragon
yeah that's all i can think of grow up
maybe maybe
um how do we think i think aisha tyler
killed it this year i'm a big fan of
hers anyway she's always great she's
aggressively enthusiastic which i really
like she's like she doesn't care whether
you think she's cool or not she's just
going to keep shouting at you yeah until
everyone loves her i'm like cool man i'm
down with that thank you
we had eve we had some special really
quite good people on stage that was eve
gilmour there was jim ryan there was
obviously matt stone and trey parker
yeah they were excellent they always are
i remember them when they were at the
xbox conference a few years ago and they
just
did not give a damn yeah they were they
seemed like they were just checked out
and we're just going to rip everyone but
so everyone picks for games of the press
conference
it's going to be for honor isn't it
straight i'm going to go i'm going to go
with south park
the fractured
butt hole this might say again one more
time i know you did for me close runner
up is watchdogs too honestly i'm pretty
excited about what i've seen so far yeah
it's it almost feels like gta 5 with
hacking mechanics which is like great
let's do it amount of personality and
color they've injected into that game
has made me more excited than i was for
the original watchdogs yeah i'm you know
i'm still going to be saying this you
know for many years to come i'm still
disappointed about no beyond good and
evil 2. also um
no prince of persia no
no look at assassin's creed
yeah i don't think any of that's super
surprising um i mean with the two-hour
press conference they clearly had enough
going on already so i think that yeah i
mean we got enough they could have cut
out the movie a bit and the extended
dance sequence at the beginning for a
game that wasn't even shown in any
capacity yeah yeah that was quick what
are you doing but i guess i mean it's a
licensed music game they'll still be
working through that they can't really i
mean they did have don't stop me now
as every time it's a great song it's in
every game ever but
um what else did we think what what were
your kind of
high points like really like getting
into the conference
i always think back to for honor yeah
yeah
was great um i i don't know this there's
something about grow up that i really
really like dig like the more i think
about it the more i and how much i
enjoyed the original one and now i'm
thinking about like being in space and
having a rocket you know jet pack and
stuff and being given more area to
explore like that's kind of it's getting
into my head now i really want to play
it and blood dragon being out now yes
yes it was a very open moment yeah so
yeah when once we get back to
england
from all this madness i'm going to sink
my teeth into that i'm really excited
about that yeah i just realized how
severely outnumbered i am here yeah yeah
we already just don't the time has come
up take over
star trek bridge crew kind of charming
as well but i'm pretty sure that it was
the interaction between some of my
favorite star trek characters and
charming more than the actual game oh
jerry ryan seven of seven of nine yep
jordy laforge bones yeah august
he's not a gamer he's a doctor
but no i mean
i'm interested to see if ubisoft are
going to take on other licenses like
star trek i mean if they're going to
make a push into vr it seems like there
is more of a scope for that when we're
watching ea yesterday they showed like
someone working with a vr headset and it
looked like a cockpit of a an x-wing
yeah you know what i mean it's it's kind
of these experiences that would lend
themselves well to vr do we think of any
others
well you will find it i mean that's
working well
you know a confusing one for me i yeah i
could see them adding like a vr
portion to steep in the future if it
does okay yeah
yeah once once like playstation
vr is out there like not something
that's
dependent on you traveling really fast
more like a they've rendered this
mountain all these mountains like and to
give you the ability to kind of fly
through them and look around just take
the eagle flight stuff and just kind of
let you explore without having to
actually race or stuff like that if you
wanna they're talking about you know
plotting your your paths and that kind
of stuff or looking back on your path so
it would be easier if you could like
jump into vr really fly through and be
like i need to take a left here learn
the patterns and then get back into the
game and go through it you know as you
would normally that might be an
interesting way to kind of extend the
life of that game or give it a new twist
but i don't know
um so
this is two out of three press
conferences today well two out of three
out of four actually there was a pc show
uh we've got sony coming up do we think
there's going to be any ubisoft presence
there
huh i think i think division might show
up again one more time now it's their
third expansion
on both xbox and playstation i don't
know
that's right actually it was at xbox i
keep forgetting and they showed up at
xbox but yeah i don't know i feel like
they'll be there for a bit just to be
like maybe in like a quick like teaser
trailer type thing maybe no one comes
out to be like hey guys yeah one of
their vr things might make a nod if they
mentioned yeah
morpheus oh well playstation beyond them
uh this was a better name it was such a
great name
for the two hours that they had i think
i think they announced as much as they
could yeah yeah
i don't know what they could possibly
have left at this point the long shot is
that sony has an exclusive which ubisoft
isn't doing much of these days yeah less
and less um but then again you never
know stranger things that have happened
like we had shenmue last year so we'll
still get some of the dlc we expected
like maybe there'll be a far cry primal
dlc you come in a playstation 4 or
something like that yeah i was a little
surprised we didn't see more out of that
i mean that game only came out you know
four months ago we haven't really heard
too much of it since its initial release
so i figured maybe that would be a
contender so maybe it's tony maybe yeah
um but that i mean you should be joining
us here at 5 30 for our sony pre-show um
thank you so much for joining me um
thank you to my lovely guests on this
couch over here for more coverage of e3
2016 make sure you keep your eyes peeled
do gamespot
you